that's so New York and it's so New York
that not a fight happened like I walked
into a a deli once to because I needed
to find your ATM in New York and I
walked in and I said hey do you have an
ATM and the guy's like nah you're gonna
buy something and I'm like nah I just
want to know if you have uh to get cash
he's like no we don't have that we if
you're a customer come in he's like go
[ __ ] yourself and I was like and I and I
was like in my head I was like this is
New York and I go like this
thank you and I walk out
you ever met this guy oh I'm the dumble
you can't argue there's something about
me you have no idea
[Music]
oh let's get rid of Rumble
now
oh no no I no I got no he signed off on
I says let's get ready oh really and he
said sure Jeffrey Dahmer I said I'm not
him dude yeah you don't look like him at
all you don't seem like him you they're
nothing like Jeffrey Dahmer right now if
Theo were here he'd be like more like
Jeffrey Dumber so
um I'll do that joke since he's not here
but yeah guess what guys I know you're
[ __ ] waiting in anticipation but my
tour it's friggin lit dude don't push me
tour is [ __ ] live now go get tickets
it's under the comments there you can
click the link but chrisley.com I'm
going to New York I'm going to Chicago
I'm going to [ __ ] all sorts of places
now we say New York and Chicago you're
in like weird places no no I'm doing the
beacon in New York okay well that's on
you just kidding I know I know and then
Chicago enormous the Beacon's awesome
actually yeah have you ever been there I
walked by it
what are you trying to do right now dude
no I'll walk by it yeah I might be a
skank fast
October 10th is that October 14th
through the 16th in Vegas but I'm also
doing this show with Rick Glassman the
great I love Rick Rick doing his own
which he's doing a live podcast in this
show it's in St Petersburg so go to
Rick's website for that I said I would
go do live podcast with him yeah I think
we're gonna do a couple of sets
Colusa Casino uh October 28th Sacramento
area come check me out and I got some
other dates there's gonna dress up like
an Indian let me ask you these questions
though have you come on out people have
you been to Midland Texas
I've been everywhere in Texas I've
texted what's Midland Texas I'll be
there Springfield Springfield Missouri I
hear that that place is Springfield's
nice is it yeah oh really yeah
Springfield's nice and what about
Seattle I'm doing but San Antonio have
you've done something you're going to
Seattle uh McCall Hall oh wait where do
the SuperSonics play that's where you're
doing no not quite not yet Portland
Oregon we have a team Portland's cool I
was watching videos on Portland uh who
who told you Portland's cool when's the
last thing you went to oh no no no no no
no that's what I was going to say I hate
my special in Portland American warrior
at Revolution Hall oh no no no no no
what was it this little I saw it how
long ago though Eric it was a long time
ago yeah oh I was there four months ago
so have you ever seen have you ever seen
Batman Dark Knight you know when Bane
takes over oh man that's what Portland
looks like now you were downtown of
course right like I was downtown yeah
and a cop came up to me off dude you got
a lot of cop fans right off duty he goes
what are you guys doing tonight I go I'm
not sure any suggesting he goes yeah go
back to your hotel do not go out it's
that bad it was then I don't know now I
wonder if it's I I don't know because I
don't think but I don't think it's I
don't think it's violent crimes I think
it's like property crimes and [ __ ] and
like no no no no no no they're not what
downtown is nice okay so there are not
after Boston yeah Boston and New York
actually but like you have to like but I
mean if it's really big like that you
have to there are Pockets that are bad
right but like if any major if it's not
so big I mean it there's some bad
[ __ ] stuff San Antonio is great you
said you're going to San Antonio yeah
I'm there in November hello it's
literally my favorite place in Texas
really if I was gonna move to Texas be
San Antonio get out of here yeah doggy
wow and oh and they have the best hope
by the way would have had so many more
victims because the gay dudes would have
been like [ __ ] yeah let's go dude it
would have been [ __ ] off
you think that Brendan's cuter than
Jeffrey Dahmer oh oh bro this guy's this
guy's thinking about the [ __ ] Series
where the [ __ ] model plays him for
[ __ ] sake the real Jeffrey
looks like Nick it doesn't look like me
wait first of all Nick's not a bad
looking dude all right
hold on a second yeah no no no Nick you
have Richard Ramirez teeth with Jeffrey
Dahmer face
with an Oakland booty
[Laughter]
Richard Ramirez
isn't it wait that's uh Sir Sir
Mix-A-Lot right can you please put up a
poll you know who's better am I better
looking than Jeffrey Dahmer so real
quick can we just admit that Eric
Griffin is attracted to Jeffrey Dahmer I
know he's saying that you did though
A or B and I'm I'm not better looking
than Jeffrey Dahmer
oh look at the second picture
right there that's the one right there
Jeffrey Dahmer you know it looks goofy
here is is is fine looking in a picture
there's no picture where Jeffrey
diamonds better look at me by the way
I'm not an L.A I'm not an LA nine all
right by no means am I a nine in L.A
compared to Dahmer though how dare you
Eric I think Dahmer kind of looks like
Chris a little bit that because you know
I have stuff behind my face like where
I'm like he doesn't look like Chris you
know I get cereal no he'll bring up that
that's a bad picture my face is there it
is
right that right there look at that
let's me no not that one my face is that
that's actually a good picture the one
the the one around where I look like a
blackjack dealer with the vest on Boom
I'm not better looking than him no bro I
I I agree with you bro I I think he's
just equal
no dude you're you're at the gay club
Brendan you know you're like okay you
know what Eric is he's dumber and you're
like a hater okay okay let me see you're
seeing Jeffrey Dahmer dance
[Music]
have you seen him dance in the series
you don't know how Jeff Jimmy drummer
could have been like no you're
romanticizing Jeffrey Dahmer because
you're a [ __ ] white what's the
problem you're doing what White Chicks
do yeah I'm sending them letters yeah
yeah yeah cause these white chicks on
Tick Tock is like did you see it though
does anybody else feel sorry for Jeffrey
Dahmer it's like [ __ ] are you he used
to eat it's not even feel sorry the
whole serial killers are hot thing it
just drives me nuts I know me too it's
like no you're saying that because you
live in a fantasy world you don't
actually think a Serial Killer's hot you
meet one of these [ __ ] and
they're just like oh hey hey yeah they
don't like personality well Ted Bundy
had a Charisma anybody that does
anything really well they don't seem to
be like a good husband father uh good
whatever because look what happens you
know what I mean they're just to be
great at this thing friggin all over
there prolific serial killer yeah look
like Michael Jordan not the best husband
or father right Tom Brady's getting a
divorce it don't seem like he was the
best might be a good dad though sounds
like a good dad good dad you don't want
to be married to him yeah but also with
Tom I can't only have one headshot in
the household that isn't them the rules
headshot you only have one head meaning
only one person can be in entertainment
the
rules
all this time yeah
I don't know anyway well Eric I think
John Wayne Gacy is better looking new so
what's up wow wow
that guy not only is that guy not only
yeah
[Laughter]
not a bad looking guy that's a good
comparison all right now you're gonna go
there wow really no only when he has the
makeup on on the clown face yeah I will
say though I would say Bert Kreischer I
will say though so John Wayne guess he's
a very unfortunate looking man and the
thing more about him is when you hear
video of him you're like it's even more
unfortunate my point is that Jeffrey
Dahmer is a fine looking guy and then
you hear him talking stuff and it's
worse yeah because he's on the spec
right okay well the let's not you know
nobody again nothing against people on
the Spectrum you can be on the Spectrum
and not serial kill yeah I don't know
it's one of my favorite shows most of
the time they are really great
accountants you know what I mean
really good accountants but killers
think about all right we owe money here
and think about crushing numbers think
about what's the difference between say
Pat Riley and Hitler right wow hot cake
hot hot day I mean
yes
what I'm saying is like you know one is
like a very charismatic leader of people
and then one decided to do some evil
[ __ ] the other guy decided to lead black
men to hit you know
championships well one's a sociopath I
know but what I'm saying is that same
sort of like whatever that Charisma is
you can use their quality you can use it
for good Charisma is is currency
Charisma wins championships you can use
it for good and you can use it for evil
also also known basketball helps Ted
Bundy could have been like freaking uh
uh they do that owned apple or freaking
Elon Musk I don't think one of these
type of people I don't think so yeah
I'm saying or he could have been a
comedian um you know what I mean like
what's like like Chris is one step away
from like happened imagine the car
window in yeah yeah pulling someone out
having heads in his freaking
refrigerator not all of them but Ted
Bundy was smart like he represent
himself as a lawyer and before they sent
him to death the judge goes you know
it's a shame he goes you'd been a
[ __ ] fine uh lawyer this is what I'm
saying man well no he's the only one the
rest of them are morons
it's hard to look but they're the
tenacity and the hard work and the
[ __ ] dedication convinced the police
Dedication that this 14 year old kid was
his boyfriend that's crazy bro and they
and the cops helped him back again take
away from there that had a lot to do
with those cops are stupid homophobia
that had a lot to do with homophobia
yeah they didn't want they thought they
used that guys we are very
well versed in in these serial killers
it's not about the circuit all I'm
saying is like look imagine these serial
killers and stuff at a time when there
is now social media they're saying right
now and say same right now in L.A that
there is a serial killer right now I'm
always it's Sacramento get this Stockton
there's always it's in Stockton and I
just left the day after they were like
serial killer and stuff he doesn't scare
I'm going to San Jose this weekend so
hope you never come to San Jose this
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm too big of
a Target but the thing is is he's he's a
[ __ ] serial killer because he just
drives a gun shooting bro you ain't
gonna stop and pick up the body and eat
them then I'm not into it use poison use
poison be a Strangler you know have some
makeup talk about a suit do knifing you
can't just [ __ ] willy-nilly pop pop
you're just a drive-bye you're basically
a gangster you're a drive-by you're a
gang banger just shoots random people
um they had the social media imagine a
Bundy oh yeah you know done oh no golden
age of the serial killers over like in
the from the 70s to the 80s they were
popping yeah but now these new circles
are getting lazy they have no they have
no like gimmick their marketing's all
off crime was [ __ ] nuts in the 80s
and 90s way worse than now way worse
than this dude I looked at some videos
online I watch YouTube videos dude I
don't know if you guys watch YouTube
videos but I watch YouTube videos like
I'll watch the Youtube videos of like
cities and like how they were popping in
the [ __ ] Whatever Whenever they were
popping and then whenever they were in
Decline bro Oakland was like well still
it was well I know I know it still is
but it was I mean a guy got stabbed
after my show yeah like I got stabbed
after my show do you know that for your
merch I heard he's like do you have a
large well a large dick [ __ ] this you
ran out I'm a thick boy he did an
overhand too like this like oh wow no
but he he got stabbed after my uh I'm
after my show did he die no he didn't
die he got uh
why I don't know it's Oakland so Chris
is like so I gave him 50 off merch no no
no
all right I'm looking through my stories
people tag me and stuff and look at this
I was talking about how we were staying
in the four safest blocks and um you
breathe too loud huh
debris is too loud
they just left the Chris Delia show okay
[Music]
one of the people at my show got [ __ ]
he's leaking holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he got
stabbed I hope he's he seems like he's
okay hey go to the hospital he went on
to do more stories you bring too loud
huh I would have done the story too yeah
I know bro open up the doors it's
Enrique I hope hey man I got stabbed at
your show [ __ ]
dude isn't that crazy yeah
this guy's always got information we ah
okay but he still got stabbed this guy's
like always one yeah yeah we're not Fox
News here man we're taking it from
social media I am I'm trying to get a
hold of him for a patreon episode yeah
oh so we're gonna try and talk to him
that's producer in the [ __ ] game
apparently so I always tell you I always
say this you want to fire him through
your stride fire for four years
I keep them on his game yeah we need to
be good we need he needs to always be
thinking he's about to get fired we're
gonna fire him dude
promotion yeah so here's the deal we
need a diversity leader in this place so
this guy got [ __ ] stabbed and he was
leaking he went three inches in his
chest three inches do we believe this
that this is what he said oh you
wouldn't get him on they said and uh an
inch away from his lungs that would have
been real leaking he would have been
dead dude I'm gonna get the story yeah
we'll get the story maybe on the patreon
hopefully he'll he'll answer but anyway
he's a comedian I look up on the thing
and he does yeah what an interesting guy
Tommy T's that would be for sure Eric
headlines Eric goes to tummy T's yes
[Music]
let's take a little break from chatting
with the boys Eric Griffin and Chris
Dalia because I'm here to tell you about
Avast that's right it's a global leader
in cyber protection for more than 30
years it's trusted by over 435 million
users and prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every freaking month all
right digital safety privacy it's
everything if you're at the coffee shop
you're surfing online you're on your
laptop you're on your phone you don't
just trust everybody you can't these
days someone hacks in your stuff it's
not going to be fun a vast new
all-in-one solution of ass one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features and
because they believe in essential
protection should be available to
everyone a free version of of asked is
also available and still includes
award-winning free AV free VPN free
firewall and much much more and also
there's a premium version which offers
even more advanced protection right and
you can do it on multiple devices they
got you covered man a vast privacy
features keeps my identity and my
actions hidden I don't want everybody
knowing what I'm doing I don't want my
you know personal information Bank
information stuff like that passwords
you gotta use a vast man we got you guys
covered anti-virus you're talking about
award-winning antivirus VPN listen you
don't want people to know exactly where
you're looking at stuff at where you're
logging in that VPN allows you to be
secure online wherever you're at so you
don't have to worry about cyber crime so
if you want to check out Avast all you
gotta do all you gotta do is by
supporting The King The Sting in the
wing constantly take control of your
online world with a vast one helps you
stay safe from viruses attacks
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes learn more about a vast one
at avast.com the NFL season is popping
it's been fun not if you're a Denver
Broncos fan it's been a tough season for
your boy but also my Rams also suck
Chargers are okay it's tough all right
it's tough unless you're a Philly fan
but listen
if you want to watch football and make
some money with your buddies you can and
you got to use the official sports
betting part of the NFL we talk in
touchdowns big plays even bigger wins
new customers can bet just five dollars
on any NFL team to win and get 200 in
free bets if you do check this out in
addition to the usual bets everyone can
boost their winnings with DraftKings
stepped up same game parlays all right
you got big games coming up this week
bet on your favorite team make some
money and also to make things even
sweeter you can throw down on a stepped
up same game parlay once per game all
season long all right download the
draftking sports app right now use promo
code Kats to get 200 in free bets if
your team wins when you place a five
dollar bet on any football game the
codes Kats only a draftking Sportsbook
an official sports playing partner the
NFL middle and age eligibility
restrictions by C show notes for details
DraftKings all right so let's take some
that's good I like when we have a bunch
of good banter up front hey you know
what you know what the little this just
goes to show you I'm having awful day I
woke up just a [ __ ] storm because of
work stuff yeah my literally my phone
was on fire I was in the worst mood
before I got in here and just you bring
me coffee fully redeemed myself see it
made you feel good yeah how many ships
have you taken so far oh you're just
saying the fact that I thought yes
should the black part of that hat be
like like that is isn't that a sign that
that's the back of the hat or something
you know what that means it means
trouble you're trouble with the X on
there this is my boy Daisy May hats to
make you should you know how cool you're
looking at you want to put this on let
me see you know you know how [ __ ]
sweet you'd look in a hat I don't know I
don't know if I'm hat ready
you seem like a hacker did you send that
to your girl she's like dude get here so
I can swallow that day you actually do
seem like a hat guy I feel like I'm an
Archie no you know what he looks like
when he wears it a pi yeah hey Eric
Griffin I've got paragraphs
or a photographer with a big flash just
no he's a it goes you get to go like
this too
[Music]
and you're holding the Flash
yeah you're trying to get like a 1705
after like nobody moves don't move for
15 minutes just pictures loaded
I don't know it should be a hat guy when
do you become a hat guy my boy my boy
Daisy you know what this isn't bad
so he makes hats for post Malone's easy
top like he's a b it's all custom so
they're all one of one I don't know I
would recommend for you you don't like
cats though bro if that's your outfit
wore that hat and it wasn't a joke yeah
but your head is just
your forehead is so big I know with the
glasses right there you still have a
normal sized forehead
like the glasses are here and he still
has a normal human foreign
[Laughter]
like if you draw some fake eyebrows up
here and then put your glasses like this
the fly dude you look you have good hair
though yeah I just love hats okay
yeah I love those Daisy man hats have
probably six of them I have an off-white
one am I just finishing that I want to
have an off-white one Jesus Christ they
have the off-white laces on it the
orange off-white laces on your hat yeah
what are you like a pilgrim showing up
with the buckle on his hat like that's a
new a hypebeast the Indians what's with
the [ __ ] belts on your hat it's a
hypebeast pilgrim no but Bryn didn't
have like a wrestling belt right here
it'd be like the Intercontinental
Championship
it's so heavy another another person
just sitting on it I'm like this what
it's fashion
reminds me of that key and peels oh that
was so funny
he's got that woman making the Hat oh my
God he's holding her up like this on the
platform that was something oh man dude
they were that that show was so perfect
for the internet the sketch of all time
man yeah it just you just grabbed these
like what was the bit was it
one up in each other because you come
with a double paper like oh cool
yeah at the end he had the lady making
the Hat on his head and he was all like
thank you
all right let's go let's see what we got
here for uh the show
um and uh nice here we go
I'm just gonna wear the hat the whole
time all right what up boys
all right Debate Club going to a Chris
D'Elia show
but getting stabbed right or going to a
chin and browse show
but not getting stabbed oh Chris
deleon's probably a lot funner you'll
have a night full of laughs tons of
people there great Vibes but till the
end of the night you get stabbed right
out of the hospital chin and brow show
probably not as many people there like
we're performing this weekend in Plano
Texas at a festival you can come see us
if you'd like it will be fun but you not
as big as you don't get stabbed right
but not as many people well I mean maybe
if the festival is popping almost like
Plano Texas though who knows but also
Texas yeah but not too many stabbings
more guns right so there's that Shin
fans you know they're being Chinese
stars that's way back in the day I don't
hang out with any gangsters well I'm not
buying it yeah but do you ever really
leave the gang like you try to leave
hey chin do you want us to jump you out
right now yeah we can just jump you in
out of the gang we'll jump you if you're
out of the gang and you're in the pocket
jump him out is that does that even work
oh you have to do that oh you gotta get
judged out yeah to get out Oh I thought
you must do like a really high ranking
guy you have to get jumped out Oh I
thought you had you can't you're a real
high-ranking guy you can't leave but I
can leave but you'll get destroyed and
they'll probably come after you later
too you have to be jumped up oh Jesus
yeah there's not listen there's no
promises we'll give you a few days to
rest right right right yeah jumping out
I never was in the game I was just
around them they were my best friends at
the time he was like a lot lizard I went
this direction they went this direction
yeah yeah it's probably because he
started singing they were like yeah yeah
they were like where and again he was
like bye bye bye bye bye dog could you
please quit Dancing now this begs the
difference this is China on Jelly roll's
tour buses watch out hammered so just
this weekend I know I never get this
hammered where are you he's not on the
bus it's the Honda Center Anaheim jelly
rolly look [ __ ] look dude I'm freaking
you're you're on six like two uh
straight up dude you've never seen
somebody drink like you wow and then he
forces everybody else to drink it's a
good time yeah it's great Nick would
have oh no Nick you were there in
Nashville I've got lit up with that in
Nashville because he'll just bring a
tray full of 30 shots you're like
there's four of us wow he's like yeah
it's for us I'm like he's a good artist
man he's got he's got a great one he's
the sweetest dude yeah
no we're just because he's homies with
Brandon really good friend of mine yeah
and then he just I know before he was
gay and now he's like does he ever get
wobbly like that or no no he's not never
I mean that helps he's been drinking all
his life
and he'll drink uh tequila like my
doctor said if I keep drinking I'm gonna
die but he said tequila is okay like you
said Doctor jelly I was like who's your
doctor yeah to rock because it's the
Agave or whatever the doctor he goes
he's over there the guy's like yeah yeah
yeah
he has shots in his yeah and he's one of
those old doctors that's got like the
metal thing yeah
[Music]
dude [ __ ] yeah man hey I would tell you
the time I was uh
I was it was my first time headlining
the comedy so I was in the bedroom I was
all excited like I wonder where they'd
asked me to do this like six years ago
turns out there's like six people in the
crowd and it was the the opening game of
the World Series with the Dodgers so
there's nobody there so I feel like a
piece of [ __ ] but then Dave Chappelle
walks in he's in the Green Room he's
like hey you're running the show I'm
like yeah the headliner he's like you
mind if I do a set man is that cool with
you I'm like sure you do whatever
whatever you want right so we're in the
green room talking and there's like I'm
feeling so sick there's only seven
people in there and me and him are
vibing like this is so [ __ ] dope man
Dave Chappelle and then he's vaping and
I go oh it just ruined our relationship
he probably hates me to this day if he
even remembers me he's vape and I go oh
you know those are worse for you than
cigarettes he goes what the [ __ ] you
just said
you know the Vapes actually worse for
you than cigarettes he goes who told you
that like oh it's just what to say he's
like who says that I'm like oh [ __ ] dude
wow he's like my doctor says better
that's why he told me started vaping
like but I don't think it is
and he's like all right man and just
walked off never talk to him again I
ruined my relationship with Dave
Chappelle over Vape he might have saved
his life though no because he's still I
still see him all the time baby still
and now Rogan's Vape right thing I feel
like I did I tried to get back I see
people going back and forth man yeah I
know you know what I mean I see like a
couple fun no but a friend of mine will
be like uh you know was vaping then
here's this yeah yeah back to cigarettes
bro the real thing is don't do any of
that I know just do rogue nicotine I had
a buddy who come on I had a buddy who
you know nicotine suppresses your
appetite right I had a buddy who
wanted to lose weight so he got the
nicotine patch and he did it so much
that he's like I gotta start smoking
dude then he started smoking biggest
[ __ ] move of all time well hold on did
he lose weight
he was always thin he's an actor he was
like some [ __ ] you know what I mean
his name is Adrian Brody no no yeah
that's how he got first yeah you know
what though I will say this though
Public Service Announcement you should
be careful a lot of times people are
trying to quit smoking and they use the
nicotine patches and uh but then you
know what you shouldn't do is like don't
have the nicotine patch and then take
some nicotine gum and then smoke because
you're yeah yeah because you're I know a
kid he had he had a heart attack and
died oh oh I didn't have a heart attack
but I passed out walking in my car I
passed out walking my car doing what I
had a nicotine patch on before I found
Rogue and they saved my life thank you
wrote Nick's team uh but before I was
using Rogue I had the nicotine patch and
chewed the gum the Nick red gum yeah and
I didn't realize that you can overload
on yeah I'm just walking like
oh [ __ ] popped up
all good baby stop doing it wow cold
turkey after that you stop doing it yeah
yeah but did it cut you it's like that
scene from Wolf of Wall Street where he
thinks he got away but
I got problems but uh to answer the
question we probably go to a little brow
[ __ ] yeah go to little bro you didn't
want to get stabbed but also go to both
yeah go to both go to both go to places
yeah well you got to fly back and forth
but you know we're gonna get tickets
Chan
um on my buy all my Instagram I don't
know the actual nice okay
yeah but now you have to figure out how
to spell it yeah
this is the difference between icons
that made it better this is the
difference between our crowds I had a
guy show up because it's a you can have
a license to carry in San Diego asked
Enrique about this he was there okay
this guy shows up with a AR-15 on his
honest oh my God like [ __ ] like keys
of Special Forces and he goes I'm here
for Ben shop show two tickets and like
well yeah but you can't come in with
your gun is why I have a license to
carry like no we get that but do you
have to bring it in here you say well if
something happens oh my God and they're
like but yeah and then he's like go ask
Brandon I bet he approves of it and I
was like ooh make a statement yeah so
they're like hey this guy has a giant a
semi-automatically I was like last
episode that's why you gotta be careful
just tell him can he leave in the car
yeah and he was like yeah cool put in
the car
those aren't the guys you have to worry
about no sure you're not gonna access it
yeah you're not gonna announce it but
but you also don't want him to get
pissed off like you do a joke and he's
just like ah don't like that one or he's
just always just like this at the punch
at this setup he's just like
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying he's
got you in his crosshairs like and he's
like okay I like that one look at this
look at this but I'd rather have that
than the guy comes in with it
they know about you they know you have
guns but like they think that like we're
all against guns like I am not against
no just you two yeah no no I'm not
against guns but like we don't need
against guns no we don't need uh those
at comedy shows I'm not you know what by
the way since you're gonna try to put me
on blast I'm not against guns then you
know the technology just need to be
upgraded what's that oh right yeah yeah
yeah why are we still shooting little
pieces of metal at people with lethal
Force right what do you want lasers yeah
where's the stun guns where's the phone
yeah like Rick and Morty like the lasers
from Rick and Morty yeah you know what
I'm just saying man that's the the thing
the people that are laughing every time
people fight about guns you know who's
laughing at us the gun companies yeah of
course because they got these little
they're not upgrading to technology
in the same way that we have electric
cars and you know we have phones and
stuff now Eric's like I want sharks with
lasers they had the technology but it's
cheaper to make a a thing that fires and
shoots little pieces of metal you know
and then we could just upgrade the
Technologies upgrade the technology to
[ __ ] people up more no to like without
you don't need lethal you don't need
lethal Force it's true that's all
sometimes you do no you don't I disagree
you don't I just no you don't you don't
agree you you well you don't though
because you assuming the bad guys are
gonna have those same yeah lasers no no
here's what I'm trying to say dude if
you're if I'm [ __ ] hot guys
if that guy has like whatever right it's
like and you have the one then I just
want something that does I wish you want
one a thing that it stops them like
they're frozen yeah exactly you know
they're just like frozo yeah then you
can walk up talk yeah hold no hold on
hold on it's reality yeah
update I guarantee you that technology
is available but it's probably not cheap
as it is to shoot little pieces of metal
sound wave use sound waves and [ __ ]
whatever they're just like oh that's
enough they go bunk and they go
does they have to be lethal Force that's
what I'm saying yeah but I'm not against
guns right I feel like gun well you know
somebody that's a gun nut that
[ __ ] knows everything about guns
they got a gun safe no gun safety they
know how to like you know what I mean
they'll start the ones we're talking
about yeah I understand what you're
saying and and honestly this
conversation's done let's move on all
right let's look at this guy here he
brought you about it before we get to
this guy uh someone else sending the
cats in the wild they actually saw [ __ ]
in concert and said they had a great
time okay let's see it
I want y'all think of someone
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a Transformer and he transforms
into a couch
no you know what he did he went the
whole out and I'm just like oh all right
will you stay here we'll go get the bad
guy no he went into Hot Topic and was
like I'll take all of it you walk into
his room and you sit down and he's like
hey bro
get off me
his head is just right
here
he's like bro you're sitting on me let's
take another little break from the
shenanigans here thick boy Studios on
King The Sting the wing and the
thing uh I will see you this week in San
Jose Thursday Friday next week I'm in
Salt Lake City Utah Wise Guys get you
some come see the thick boy but listen
you fellas out there you're thinking
about popping a big question all right
you're thinking about popping the
question you know I'm talking about
getting down on one knee doing the right
thing well I'm here to help you guys out
it's time to make that big moment even
more special with my friends at Blue
Nile all right blue now what is it I'm
glad you asked blue now is an all
original online dealer all right blue
now offers the largest selection of
independently graded diamonds and pieces
priced significantly lower than the
retail stores blue now has helped
millions of couples create the perfect
engagement ring they're easy online
tools that you choose the diamond shape
size clarity as well as setting style
that's a big deal fellas blue Niles
bench Jewelers will then help you
handcraft her perfect one-of-a-kind
engagement ring looking for a piece of
fine jewelry to make a very special
Milestone we got you man blue now has
jewelry experts on hand 24 7 to help you
out you can call chat whatever you want
to do shop stress free with my friends
at Blue now they have 100 satisfaction
guaranteed all Blue Nile orders are
insured and shipped for free and
discrete little packets so it doesn't
give away they also offer overnight
shipping if you're in a rush some of you
guys are man listen I got my girl these
two uh rose gold
rings from Blue now she won't take him
off she sleeps them showers in them she
loves them they're fantastic better than
any store I've ever gotten a ring or
diamonds from they're fantastic and we
saved a ton of money make your moment
Sparkle with blue now go to bluenow.com
use code Kats to save 50 on your
purchase of 500 or more that's
b-l-u-e-n-i-l-e.com code k-a-t-s to save
50 on your purchase of 500 or more
bluenile.com code Kats
let's see what this little Latino is
let's see what he wants his favorite
movie's training day no doubt I like his
hair his toupee yeah let's do it yo
cat's crew what up Nick Chin everybody
in the back what's up gang gang buzz
buzz great Ring Chris sworn and uh Eric
all right Mike's King you're singing is
for you crowd surfing your baby so the
rock can hold it
I didn't see it this was hilarious video
check this out dude I got the video
before you even play it where's the
Rockette where he's crowd where they're
crowd serving Mexico he's just in Cancun
like sipping no no no no no no
Mexico not Cancun Mexico oh he's in like
deep Guadalajara said not white yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what the South
Texas because Chris said not the safe
man yeah not white Mexico but you have a
sweet yeah they're kind of Mexico where
they were like hold my baby so it's
blessed like that kind of you know what
I'm talking about like or they're like
cold might be we're giving them up for a
sacrifice
hold him for good luck like that
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
well that baby's like what in the [ __ ]
it's like Darren aronofsky's mother
yes yeah totally
how about the rock give me a vast no
shirt
what a great way to find out that you're
the father
there's just some woman in the crowd
send him his baby
you were here a year ago [ __ ]
this this is your baby that would be a
great moment where he just goes oh my
God throw it back
[Laughter]
I mean what's more dangerous this or
when Michael Jackson hung his baby over
the balcony well that was way more
dangerous
random strangers crowd surfing your
[ __ ] kid to the Rock true but it's
not that high up number one number two
the rock is very capable and Michael
Jackson uh is very frail oh you've never
seen him dance okay all right good point
good I mean but what's somebody doing
okay and he's also holding by his neck
dude he's off do that like well he's
just bad with babies he's gonna do
though like like you know as the baby's
going towards the rock somebody's like
got it and then you just see a dude I
know I know that happened but here's the
thing the rock if I'm The Rock in that
situation I go like this the whole time
I'm like no no no no hey can we give it
back to the leg give it no no no no no
oh God damn it all right but you all do
this wow yeah he's like yeah first of
all sacrifice I'm gonna come down there
hold on stay there I'll come down right
right I'll be right down there you don't
need to happen at one of your shows
clearly it will yeah and the crazy part
is the baby's going to come up you can't
have no feet and then on the baby's
chest it's going to say life reps I knew
we were going from the beginning the
baby has a life ripped tattoo you would
be like
and that was you just go like this
Calvin and the corner like whoops Christ
hold me yeah pick me up now was the rock
there for like Jumanji seven or some
[ __ ] no it's for uh Black Adam
looked at your tattoos and been like
yeah I have a little bit about it I want
one of these oh really yeah does he ask
for him because you know those like
plate those stickers that they can put
on my kids I'll take it they have yeah
because they want to look like me that
the fake tattoos all over their hearts I
drew all of my tattoos that I have on
him with a marker it was really funny
because she's like he loved it
and that's how it starts oh my Tiger's
gonna have a face tattoo I said he's 14.
I'm getting another one
yeah you know what don't there's nothing
worse when you tell somebody and they go
why would you get that it's got cool
cleaning now yeah
no no no you'll like it but you know
what I'm saying I don't tell anybody
when I get that you can just cut to
Calvin on a big wheel yeah you know in
the neighborhood like they did a bad bad
thing
The Sting in the wing whiskey Pete Jared
I'm from Oregon Santino let him say for
you guys so I sent Nick to videos
and I want you guys to watch those and
let me know would you rather be Jordan
Poole getting super band punched by
Draymond Green
or would you rather be the guy who has
to uh sit on the sidelines of the Giants
game and oh collect those semen samples
like we do here in Oregon with the
horses so just take a look at those
videos and see what I mean
well who would you rather be
okay gang gang buzz buzz soar and
wow oh nice you sounded like the [ __ ]
uh
you sounded like that fluke that uh
lizzo played oh wow you know so rather
be the guy who gets punched or you
really knocked him hard what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing boom on the right he's
he's misogynizing right now it just
looks funny no he's melting them he's
milking them
it looks like he's stroking him he is
stroking it hard too and it's reverse
style which I don't enjoy oh that's
hilarious oh oh my God that's hilarious
the guy's face too
well that's so funny wow
that's so funny and the guy in the
back's so into it he's all yeah yeah
someone actually yeah I'd rather get I
mean wow
[Music]
um yeah well obviously who will deserved
that though it's also it's practice when
Draymond Green's like I'm gonna have to
step away from the team it's like what
we're talking about Brad yeah that's a
problem with cell phones that that guy
was talking [ __ ] I don't know what he
was saying but I do here's what I do oh
yeah we know what he said okay I'm too
deep into it dude you know it how do you
know yeah because you did good Draymond
Green came out and said what you said
yeah but I have two issues with this
what okay okay before you get all can I
get to my point yeah yeah first of all
violence isn't the answer this is what
I'm saying if we if the cameras are off
and then we're getting into a thing and
you guys start fighting all right that's
our business quick fight quick fight
that's our business 100 but if one if
some [ __ ] over here is recording it
it puts it out on the internet [ __ ] that
person yeah oh I agree hot take care of
that person because the thing is this
but here's the thing but you're right
don't [ __ ] it up I don't know but when
the tape gets out you do have to answer
for it right yeah of course it's the
same thing like it should have never got
out it should have never got it I'm
saying like whoever put that tape out
they need to fire that person that's
what they're trying to find out and they
need to get them the [ __ ] out of the
building but that person never payday
they [ __ ] no no they're thinking what
happens that person works for Golden
State in some capacity maybe it's the
intern some sent to a friend the friends
so stupid so immature they gotta go that
person's got to go they gotta go oh I
agree like no get out you know what I
mean bye bye bye yeah
you get put it's it's like if you have
like a text chain with your friends we
say a bunch of stuff that I like I would
never want out in public but if it gets
out in public you're [ __ ] you have to
answer for it right those are my friends
and that wasn't meant for your [ __ ]
asses yeah that's the thing that happens
and so it's so frustrating you know you
know what really takes me off too about
like some of these things that things
that get out or whatever it's like if
you talk about covid right there's like
a thing that comes on Instagram like
this needs to be fact checked and all
this kind of stuff but a [ __ ]
could just say anything about your
character or anything there's no fact
checking going on nothing there's nobody
going like well we need to make sure
that this is correct before you
disparage they can run any agenda
[ __ ] character yeah man it's on it
today you know what I mean I just it's
unbelievable man it's unbelievable you
were a good addition to this
hey I think we made the right choice are
you just frustrates me man it's just
frustration
hypocrisy you know what I mean but
anyways Draymond Green did the right
thing he had to come out he needed to
apologize he needed to answer for that
now that it's out everything in the
exactly everything said was one because
you know Michael Jordan and I'll be
talking about this on riffing with
Griffins yeah
and two uh twitch check me out on Twitch
every single day Eric Griffin gaming and
I will be solely talking about this I
might don't push me Tor chrysalia.com I
have an hour of Draymond yes whatever
his name yeah Draymond Green is actually
opening up for me Draymond Green is
actually Draymond he's open up for me in
San Jose this Thursday Friday Saturday
and then uh Carl Malone is opening up
for me in Salt Lake City next Thursday
Friday
even find Karl Malone he's on like a
farm someplace he just gets done oh man
he's opening up for you dude how about
how I know my stuff from the 80s and 90s
and I'm also being on stage in Salt Lake
City in my short shorts like Stockton
let's not wear those short shorts on
stage
oh yeah
oh that was easy yeah when you're right
you're right you know am I gonna fight
you wear hats on stage
backwards not that
I did in Nashville because Nashville and
Daisy May is based on Nashville so I
feel like you brought it to the Green
Room I was like I'll wear it makes sense
yeah send me a hat guys no don't don't
don't what are you talking about they
can send you a dope like superhero theme
one you know how some people have the
sunglasses that like you know they go
they turn into Shades like oh yeah yeah
he just has one and then he'll put
another one here
[Music]
and then he'll also have his reading
glasses
three like a fly yeah yeah he's a spider
he just rotates them
what's this Nick this is like prison he
gives his uh King of the sting at the
end but he was just recording some crazy
stuff in public
oh it's a Karen pissed off you're riding
in the bike lane walking
always
[Applause]
kill yourself public transportation oh
I mean it's good for the environment he
also added the video was taken at 5 45
a.m on my way to work oh wow the woman
in pink pants repeatedly pepper sprayed
the other woman she claims it's because
the woman threatened her kids no there
are no kids with her
your day a little excitement where is
this in New York uh San Jose oh wow oh
oh okay here Oakland so I'll avoid the
train so not this week this Thursday
Friday Saturday there's no way that's
new it's way too clean oh yeah one time
dude one time
yeah one time I was in New York and I'm
it's late I'm waiting for the subway and
there was a dude standing like you know
a little bit behind me and I just all I
did was look at him
you know because I heard somebody you
know this [ __ ] was like
what the [ __ ] your problem you know what
and I was like and I you know what I got
excited for a second because I was like
Wow New York this is mad New York
hopefully like New York is happening
right now yeah that's so funny you know
what you know what that's so New York
and it's so New York that not a fight
happened like I walked into a a deli
once to because I needed to find ATM in
New York and I walked in and I said hey
do you have an ATM and the guy's like
nah you're gonna buy something and I'm
like nah I just want to know if you have
uh to get cash he's like no we don't
have that we if you're a customer come
in he's like go [ __ ] yourself and I was
like and I and I was like in my head I
was like this is New York and I go like
this
[ __ ] you and I walk out and there's
quite no issues no issue that's how they
that's how they communicate it's
hilarious and I love it I was thinking
of the same time
the guy got even madder at me because I
was smiling yeah you know because I was
like oh [ __ ] yeah
so funny bro what what's what am I clown
you know he was like I was like nah man
it's just I'm not from here you know I'm
just trying to get on the subway New
York thank you for the experience I want
to take a selfie if I just in L.A it's
over before you oh oh I was shot yeah I
mean like not really it's like [ __ ] you
and then all of a sudden you get a call
from your lawyer what for what dude I
was at I went to I was in Seattle and I
went to the I wish I could remember the
name of the place but it's a bar
restaurant right and everybody's kind of
acting up is it the Honey hole they're
acting rude bro so I'm standing there
and I got some ketchup some french fries
yeah and I just I want to ask the guy I
go like this I want to ask again for can
I get if you guys like hey we don't
[ __ ] hail people here man we don't
what we don't hail people you don't oh
you don't us down for [ __ ] okay I'm a
human I just was like okay
like you snapped
it how do you get ketchup in here excuse
me yeah it just was like it was like no
that whole can't catch me [ __ ]
it was like the real version of that
[ __ ] restaurant you know yeah yeah
yeah
huh there's a bunch of them but yeah
yeah but dicks is just like they're
playing around yeah yeah but this play
this dude was like this is what they do
here and I thought to myself I'm never
coming to your [ __ ] [ __ ] no I
didn't get down in Seattle I was at you
know in the gay area I didn't know it I
saw the rainbows on the cement but what
I read it no whatever I went to a place
called the glory hole and they have I'm
sorry it was the honey hole okay well
nice sandwiches and they have a coffee
shop in there
the person making the coffee I don't
know the pronoun I'm just trying to get
a [ __ ] my coffee with my iced coffee I'm
trying to start my day it was you look
like me bigger way more tattoos but was
in a dress but had its back to me okay
and then they had its back I don't know
the pronouns I don't know right right
they someone else give me a coffee and I
just went it was big bigger than me hey
bro can I eat a straw yeah turns around
it's like bro no you can't get a [ __ ]
strong bro how dare I was like dude I
just want a [ __ ] stroll just give me
a goddamn so because you labeled him a
male and we're together now yeah
because you labeled her see that story
went nowhere fully redeemed myself no no
no it's a good story the whole yeah
what'd you say Tiger's father yeah so
hold on so me and him have a time
because he wanted you to she she wanted
you to say her who knows were they or
they or them wow I went hey bro can I
you know how it's just natural yeah I'm
talking I thought maybe I don't know it
was in a like a summer dress but Jack
dude when I was just like hey bro can I
get a straw what bro yeah
the whole point is queer too because the
whole point is like are we trying to
smash all of this so people should be
allowed to wear dresses and like you
know I don't give a [ __ ]
dude how about this I don't want to just
assume and cut hey excuse me ma'am what
kind of thing when you go like even if
Rachel says something funky to me bro
dude it's like dude yeah yeah so my mom
calls me bro dude I was I was at so I
was watching the new Hellraiser movie
okay yeah don't do that though well I
did and I actually liked it so better
than the 80s one
when's the last time you seen the 80s
one yeah
it doesn't hold it so so anyway I'll I'm
Eric will definitely watch it so because
it's a movie and it exists so we so I
was watching this and the Pinhead is
this uh you know it's this androgynous
kind of like I'm out no no no no but but
okay look it's a it's a cinnabite okay
it's a demon so it doesn't really matter
that's not true dude it act that
actually is it's not true because they
don't exist but it is true okay so
anyway oh is this like a little mermaid
situation no no so so I'm watching them
be true to the story no no no no so I'm
watching the movie It's supposed to be a
white male now look now look I don't
give a [ __ ] who plays this [ __ ] at all
I'm watching a movie I honestly can't
tell if it's a male or a female how
about that's a female you know that
and then when they talk it talks like
this right so that's a demon talk no I
wouldn't know I didn't that could be the
way I love playing that game in public
yeah you know you just go guy or girl
right right right you can do that in L.A
and lose lose a lot and so yeah so so I
don't know if it's a matter if you saw
it you would probably not know either at
first I thought it was women but then
after the movie goes I was like this is
a man okay so I don't know so I look up
later
and I say I look it up later right after
I watch the movie and it says it's a
woman that plays this part and I'm like
that's interesting and then I'm like
they probably chose a woman because it
you know they wanted to change things up
it's the times it's a little bit more
woke and I'm like okay but I got no
problem with it it's [ __ ] Pinhead I
don't give a [ __ ] what they're like it's
a demon from the [ __ ] underworld
right so so I'm like all right so a day
goes by okay and I watch the first
Hellraiser it's obviously a dude right
the Pinhead is obviously the original
character is a dude yes so
now now don't don't Google anything so
now I'm what I'm I I I I I look more
[ __ ] I I was like I want to see who
played the thing so I Google a YouTube
video of the woman who plays the thing
and she's like when I got the part yada
yada and I'm like what what [ __ ] and
then I Google more and it's a trans
woman so I'm like okay now I like it
okay it's fine but
they didn't lead with it's a trans woman
they were like there's now a woman
playing a thing and I get trans women or
women but it's like guys who don't
really understand the deal we have to
catch up and we don't understand it can
be distracting well it's already a demon
is tough
but it's it's not this distracting it's
like okay so do we call do we say
they're trans women or do we just say
they're women you just say it's a demon
okay you're missing the point but you
understand what I'm saying so where's
your hot take
hey Eric you appreciate this um I forget
there's some black community post this
he goes he goes Disney wants to be woke
and everybody's all upset about Little
Mermaid being black blah blah blah he
goes Disney I dare you turn Tarzan to
black men turn Tarzan to black man see
how it goes oh you don't have the balls
that's hilarious swinging on vines yeah
that's fine he was like dear you Disney
but here's but here's here's the thing
you know I just found this out the
original the person that wrote Little
Mermaid it's actually gay and the story
of course it was the story was about you
know
you know he felt like a mermaid but but
it's just a show to to have to change
yourself to be in another world yeah
yeah well The Matrix you know have you
seen the The Matrix if you watch it as
somebody who wants to change their
gender it's an incredible watch and it's
awesome I didn't think about this it's
awesome so red pill blue pill you're gay
if you watch that [ __ ] and think about
how the the creators are transgender
it's [ __ ] awesome I didn't know that
either it's awesome same thing if you
watch uh Harry Potter and you figure out
how she's a bigot it makes it so much
better okay well
anyway my point is there are definitely
some women out there that are watching
Hellraiser that see it that are like
cool nice for women and then they're
like all right when they find out the
trans thing they're like all right dude
you know because straight white women
had about [ __ ] 20 minutes where they
were the [ __ ] and then Emily Anderson no
no no no no no it was like a year and a
half ago and then and then and no where
they could get all this [ __ ] and now
it's like it now it's about people of
color and trans and straight white women
are basically white dudes now yes you
know what I mean it's hilarious they had
about 10 minutes bro and the funny part
is like the woke ones they can't
verbalize it right of course because
they're just like
I know but damn where are the parts for
the women I know
uh I was doing uh when I was doing I'm
dying up here Eric is better looking
than I was in her I mean clearly I'm
just saying do you know I don't like the
doubting I want to get on your side I do
know but uh yeah I was doing a I
remember doing I'm dying up here and
like having a conversation on set about
we were just talking about how Louis
Anderson played all right right right
right right oh so good too and I
remember in the middle of this
conversation Melissa Leo who was the
star she had feelings about it because
she's a woman right right right she was
like oh yeah they got a a man to play a
part for a woman that like there isn't a
lot of parts for you know what I mean
it's because nobody's as talented
absolutely she's one of them Melissa
lives amazing yeah she won an Oscar but
my point is like so think of that so
even think of you know you know what I
mean so it's like he wasn't Lily wasn't
that's interesting huh I mean it was a
comedy so but still yeah we won an Emmy
all right he was fantastic he went to
Emmy as a woman yeah fantastic I didn't
even do that now a few years later they
could never do that right yeah it's it's
you know oh try making a hot topic again
where Robert Downey Jr plays black guy
you know he's up for an Oscar Hot Topic
he calls it under
a god dude I ruined the name of the
movie It's Tropic Thunder they're not
even
you might as well go the [ __ ]
refrigerator dance hour it's not
fridge with your kids no or even said
like oh yeah bro he's up for Gap Kids
I'm sorry I meant Schindler's List
he just picked a story
oh my god dude
public I mean blood diamond dude
sometimes my CT will flare up at the
worst moment
[ __ ]
now I did reference Hot Topic early in
the show it's probably hot on my mind
they couldn't make Tropic Thunder now
and it's a shame thank you for moving on
there's no way no Robert Downey Junior
there's no certain shows there's certain
shows if you look back they wouldn't
even be able to make now at all either
even great like I've said this before
but they couldn't make Workaholics right
now in the same way no they couldn't
make like that bro culture yeah
three whites no it just wouldn't get
made it just wouldn't get made yeah so
you know it's a shame good luck making
friends
this is what TV used to look like and
this is actually ridiculous and if you
see this you kind of understand you got
even if you're white you understand it
look up the Roswell poster the Roswell
cast
what's Roswell though it's a show on the
CW it was like
I don't even know when it was
not mad yet either Chris here we go what
do you mean not mad yet you told me I'd
be mad at this no no no no I didn't say
you'd be mad look at it that's hilarious
literally everybody's just white no the
guy on the far left wow and I know him
do you know him yes oh yeah I know that
guy
[Applause]
yeah by the way he's a dime piece he
looks like that the fact that you can
gloss over that and not know that he's
yeah yeah is exactly why they did it
like he was Latino as [ __ ] yeah every
character back there was another one
that was that had even more people and
they're all white and that guy was not
there that one that one right there
right no bottom right there everyone
everyone waited that's so wild isn't
that wild oh this is TV man but that
well not anymore but I mean like that's
Tom Hank's son uh yeah this is still TV
today Chris what show is is all white
people like this one two three four five
six seven eight nine nine white guys
most shows are still name a show no way
Michelle that's crazy Michelle name the
biggest shows I don't watch too well
this is somebody who's not well you're
white too but you're you're white inside
I'm just saying like I'm just saying
like they're still so you'd notice more
than we would you don't think it's
getting better you don't think it's
getting better it's gonna get better I
mean better and so so you have like oh
so now there's gonna be uh the one black
neighbor now or something like that no
there's full-blowns what about blackish
no no but what I'm saying is okay so
there's the one no no I can keep naming
chosen my point the fact that you can
name the show is my point I can't name
any shows interesting yeah my point is
so you can yeah you can name I love
that's the one they go to it's just like
the people that argue about this little
mermaid you know what they say well
change black panther to White you're not
stupid you know why you could pick that
yeah because there's no others well no
yeah there's an all-white superhero it's
called The Avengers right right yeah but
hold on so all right so you're saying
that just look up just go gold NBC's
current lineup all right all right yeah
let's do this let me ask you this and
again I have no dog in this fight
I'm not on TV so I don't give a [ __ ] my
thing here is though is so America's
predominantly the the black population
makes up how much of America 15 it's
gonna mix up all of them all of the uh
you know I'm not asking that I'm not
asking no I'm not but it's just a
numbers game too and sports no it's a
number I don't know you're arguing with
me like I'm saying there should be more
of whatever well you're saying it's
still not better no my point is if I'm
trying to make money I'm gonna I'm gonna
the most money I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know I know all the majority
of you all I'm saying to you is this I
don't like when people say oh it's
better now and I'm saying like it's not
when I go to audition when I'm
auditioning and stuff when I'm looking
for parts that I'm going for it's when I
look at the cast it's all the same it's
still the same do you think it still
shows your auditions it's just this
audition for whitish
well the Quantum Leap is a good example
because now it's not a white guy right I
know but they're Vampire Diaries yeah
they have interviewed vampires that's
actually a great show with the Vampire I
want to watch it rage oh it's not like
no no no back on that so all right so
what else you ever seen it no my buddy's
in it you ever seen the movie the old
one Vampire Diaries there's not a
Vampire Diaries movie so yeah they got
listen man they're trying they're trying
to do stuff but they're trying to do
stuff and it's not working in some cases
but you still got the Connor Connors
came back on the air oh yeah yeah you
know it's still one of the numbers oh
you know what shows I was thinking about
the other day they could never [ __ ]
make Married with Children no way no Al
Bundy just the misogynist and just like
talking [ __ ] the Peggy All in the Family
no oh well that forget it they were
basically slave owners you know what I
mean yeah I mean pretty this I mean this
is pretty diverse what I'm saying is
unless you're Latin I'm saying there are
a bunch of shows like this that they're
coming out with now so you're saying but
you want more you want it all no I'm not
saying that no I hate when people say
that I take offense to that well he's
joking no no but I don't know you're
joking about people but that's how
people come up
let's say if you make I hate when people
do this if you're making an argument
about something then they want to
immediately go to like well well what
about it's like when you're no it's like
when you're talking to your your girl
and she's like and you're like and you
get on her for something and she's like
fine then I won't ever say anything ever
again right exactly yeah that's not what
I'm saying that's stupid that's what I'm
saying I'm just saying like no but you
know I'm just saying that it's still
really and for that reason that you're
saying I agree which not everything's
racism man not everything's racist or
Prejudice yeah look at sports a lot of
things it's just about it's just about
it is a money issue it is about like
when you know it's just like when you're
watching a black show when you look at
the McDonald's commercial comes on it's
always going to be you know a badass
for different shows and stuff like that
I I I'm not I'm not trying to say
whatever because like because I feel
like you can't buy Sprite anymore if
you're white the reason why I like this
interview with a vampire by the way is
because of how they're doing Vampire
Diaries no no no no I thought you're
talking about interviewing the vampire
it is
on Amazon plus it's actually and they
changed that's a hard topic they changed
the character one of the characters now
black he's like this light-skinned black
guy from New Orleans right right but the
way they're doing it it doesn't even
matter well of course that's cool
how they're doing it see I don't give a
[ __ ] if there's any factors I don't care
but I'm saying sometimes you see it and
you're just like I wonder what he did
this if you could smell the agenda if
they're pushing I'm like oh man when you
know they're not doing it because of any
reason then they think it affects their
bottom line it sucks but if you think if
they're like you know what what if we
make them black and he's from New
Orleans and then this and that and this
is back to her and it's interesting then
[ __ ] by all man it's super
interesting I love it I love but I love
it dude how
but I'm not for it all that it was more
handsome wow wow that hurts my feelings
this is all of Eric Griffin dummy again
but but that's a hard time I'm just over
here doing this yeah I'm just pressing
this but but to be fair that's mainly
dudes true and they don't know
I think they know rip and wear a hat guy
oh so it's their sister so so it's
pretty it's pretty split oh that's
pretty even
yeah
yeah and look just dudes dudes dudes
Chad Charlie Tyler Liam
it says [ __ ] Dahmer lover 95.
Tyler voted for me thank you Tyler well
it's kind of like you know it's it's we
don't know yet maybe I need a better hat
yeah no you need a bigger hat yeah it
was like a yamaka hat for first year and
it's 40 56 not not bad after a girl ask
your girl you can take this hat home be
like hey babe what do you think no she's
already I've already I've been in stores
with her and she's just looking at me
like they but they don't have these in
stores yeah that's very [ __ ] up this
guy
much of a hat to me it's borderline
Cowboy I'm thinking of one of those like
Fedora or something like that you know
so you look like Charlie Chaplin I'm out
I'm out I quit the show
that'd be too much yeah that's it all
right look christian.com my new my new
tour General on sale just went on I'm
coming to all the spots I love the name
uh yeah don't push me uh don't push me
merch dude I got the joke don't push me
we can get it yes we have those on
chrisley.com but the official tour
shirts you can only get in person which
is uh really been selling that's what I
do so I know I know I may have gotten
that idea from you you did okay
okay
and I'll be in San Jose this Thursday
Friday Saturday San Jose Improv come get
you some if the serial killers up there
don't be cool man all right be [ __ ]
cool dude and then next week I'm in Salt
Lake City Utah Wise Guys Thursday Friday
Saturday the week after that uh October
27th 28th I'm in Calgary Canada at the
rooftop downtown the Thursday show is
damn near sold out so we add a show on
Friday get you some right now in
November San Antonio Houston you're up
baby tickets at thickboy.com also we
just Europe he said you're up you're up
sounded like Europe yeah
we just uh restocked that thick nectar
tiger thick is restocked go to thick boy
order it come to your doorstep you're
welcome
skank fast St Petersburg with Rick
Glassman and
Colusa Casino 28th come check me out
yeah we did it boys
[Music]
how many times I gotta make this song
[Music]
[Music]